en el estadio del Santos últimos
preparativos antes de un funeral que
pasara la historia del fútbol y de
Brasil en esta ciudad costera donde el
Eterno número 10 jugó en el Santos
Fútbol Club Se declaró un periodo de
luto de siete días todos los habitantes
se sienten un poco huérfanos
el cuerpo de Pelé se ha ido pero el alma
de Pelé está aquí en el estadio y en el
cuerpo de todos los brasileños
yo Araujo fue el peluquero del rey del
fútbol durante unos 60 años y no es sin
nostalgia que evoca a Pelé
aún era un niño cuando vino por primera
vez podía ver que era un buen jugador
pero no esperaba que se convirtiera en
el rey hasta su muerte
él era un símbolo Brasil y el mundo han
perdido en símbolo
y perdió un mundo
un símbolo al que los brasileños no
dejan de rendir homenaje como en
nochevieja en esta playa de Santos donde
un espectáculo de drones que repasaba la
carrera de Pelé se mezcló con los
tradicionales fuegos artificiales
conocía pelea a través de mi padre y
desde entonces soy seguidor del Santos
agradezco a Pelé todo lo que ha hecho
todos los brasileños todos le estamos
agradecidos
los brasileños podrán verle por última
vez este lunes cerca del estadio del
Santos donde el féretro de Pelé estará
expuesto en un velatorio después hará
una parada frente a la casa de su madre
de 100 años de edad antes de su funeral
el martes en la intimidad de su familia